[Music]
darren joins us in alberta canada darren
welcome to the ramsay show
hey how you guys doing today great how
can we help
so
i am just starting out as a young family
i have one little kid 22 years old
and has absolutely zero
um
financial
sort of savvy if you know what i mean i
never learned how to treat money i
could have saved a ton when i was
younger but didn't
you said you're 22. you were stuck
living
22 yes oh you you act like you were like
a very old man with no time left
that's what it kind of feels like dude
most people wish they weren't starting
yet brother you're good man i don't know
that's kind of why i'm trying to turn
this all around because at the moment
how things are going it looks like i'll
be working till i'm 80. wow we can
change that i don't want to do that why
do you feel that way what's your
financial situation do you have a lot of
debt
i
unfortunately do well actually
fortunately we do not have much only
about two grand okay uh in credit cards
just
recently starting to look into the baby
steps but every time we try to get our
thousand dollar
uh emergency savings put down
uh
since it's winter with covet my hours
are cut there's no work really yet going
at the moment so we end up cutting into
it just to pay our ordinary bills
we don't eat out we don't spend extra
money we don't do anything
and like i've already started doing
running door dash and
taking on as many extra side jobs as
possible just to make sure
we have enough
how can we
set like how can we change
things enough
what do you do for a living man what's
your day job
i want a hydrovac truck
for an environmental company like you'd
think it'd have a little more work but
winter has
almost no work and competition is
beating us out yeah
so
what do you make a year man
about forty thousand forty thousand is
that all of the household income
yes my wife doesn't work we have a
little boy at home and uh
yeah so you owe two thousand dollars
yeah okay managed to wheel it down yeah
so i'd like to get rid of the credit
cards entirely oh absolutely absolutely
so i'm gonna let george walk through the
baby steps but i want to back out thirty
thousand feet okay
okay
brother you're in a you're in a better
spot than you think you are
you're it's cold and it's been dark the
last few months and you sound beat down
how old's your baby
he's eight months eight months so i want
to tell you i've got two little ones
myself
it's ex you're in the season of eight
months when it's exhausting you can't go
outside because it's zero or it's
negative zero where you are
all of this weighs down on you what the
way that i hear in your voice is a
like you're under one of those anxiety
blankets those weighted 50 or 80 pound
blankets or 40 pound blankets and
like your soul has left you you are not
in bad shape financially brother you are
way ahead of the game
i think the question you and your wife
need to ask yourself is is this where we
want to live
if this is going to be the financial
reality of the the job i work in now and
by the way since i was 22 i've probably
had five to six to seven different jobs
a couple of different careers so you're
you're good man
but i want you to look at this with
optimism not with it's all coming down
because you're 22 man you are just
getting started and you only owe two
grand the number of calls we get from 22
year olds who owe 100 grand
is is is astronomical right so you're in
a good spot i want you to look at this
through um
joy not through it's all over is that
cool
okay all right good foundation there so
darren uh it sounds like to me that you
don't have a lot of margin in your
budget every month
i've actually never even made a budget
well every day is the day my friend i'm
i'm gonna hook you up with ramsay plus
that's our year-long membership and it's
gonna get you connected to every dollar
our budgeting tool austin will pick up
after our call's over and get you
connected with that i also want you to
go through the financial piece
university videos with your wife do this
as a family start budgeting and you're
going to see where your money's going
because right now it sounds like you're
not really sure why there's no money
left at the end of the month
and so i want to know exactly where
that's going
we did crunch it all together
and
we did figure out exactly how much more
we would need to accomplish just the
bills
good
and you may need to pick up some extra
side jobs you may need to supplement
that find something you're good at and
go see if your neighbors need their
driveway shoveled i mean it can be
anything get creative this is not
forever it feels like it is but this is
a short run at the moment i actually
even make donuts on the weekend just to
cover up that's awesome
at some point you're gonna have to have
a hard conversation about is this the
job for you a job that doesn't offer any
work in the in the winter time
that doesn't sound tenable or
sustainable and if competitions eat
eating your company alive it may be time
for you to say okay in two years what do
i want to be do i want to be a nurse
practitioner in five years do i want to
be a nurse in two years do i want to own
my own truck in three years do i want to
have a mechanic whatever those things
are start planning for those things now
um
but man there's a lot of yeah we've
already done this we've already done
this
you gotta start this thing with your
attitude brother and say sweet this is
falling apart sucks now i'm on to the
next now what's gonna what's you know me
what's gonna hap be there for me and my
family go get it man yeah you're 22 with
two grand in debt you're gonna look back
at this six months from now and you're
gonna be out of debt you're gonna be
working on that fully funded emergency
fund of three to six months of expenses
and then you're not gonna be worried
about the hours and what's going to
happen you're going to have what we call
financial peace and after that you're
going to begin investing and saving for
that that kid's college and paying off
the house early and doing all kinds of
amazing things and so i want you to
dream about that future and let that
vision fuel this fire uh where you go
you know what i'm gonna do whatever it
takes right now yeah i'm gonna look back
and say remember when things were crazy
at my job there was no hours we were
doing whatever it took to get by and
those are the stories you're gonna be
able to tell your son
and so get plugged into the stuff i'll
have austin pick up and make sure you
get connected to ramsey plus and that
will walk with you along this journey to
make sure that you know exactly what the
right next step is
perfect thank you for that darren good
call john yeah man man but it is
interesting
that's a 22 year old guy who thought my
life's over yeah i have two grand in
debt i thought he was going to say i'm
64. i have nothing in retirement i lost
my job and i have a hundred thousand
dollars in debt and almost
almost all of the time i hear somebody
with that level of
despair yeah there's there's life
circumstances going on somebody's
marriage is in trouble someone's got an
eight month old and they're in the
doldrums of winter in canada right
whatever it may be
and it's easy to see a little roadblock
block a little speed bump as this giant
mountain and it's just not you just
gotta back out far enough and go all
right man i thought this was gonna be it
i'm 22. dude i was a high school coach
when i was 22. and since then now i have
a youtube show i mean who knows where
this thing's going yeah uh but you gotta
get out there and hustle and you gotta
say all right this isn't working this
ship has got a hole in it so i gotta get
another boat and go find another job
yeah and that's a great reminder for
anyone listening because no matter what
age you are you always feel like it's
too late for me right right and i've i
mean i'm 42 and i just lost my job or
i'm i'm 18 and i don't know what i want
to do with my all over it's not it's
never too late to take over 62. start
over again yep start over again 70 just
start over again just keep getting back
up keep getting back up keep getting
back up